tell us your keanu reeves story i love
this story
so tell us tell us when you first met
keanu reeves
uh it was about 25 years ago
the matrix had just come out i
was on my way to pick up a script to
read for an audition
so i wasn't really wearing any underwear
i was wearing sweat
and uh and my favorite my favorite
college
football t-shirt and it it was worn i
mean it was see-through
okay no underwear guys um oh this is in
the details okay yeah
and my car hadn't been washed because i
always parked underneath the tree
and there was bird crap all over the
back of it
and it broke down like in this very posh
area of beverly hills
and there was a cafe and all of these
people were sitting out there and the
cars were honking
nobody would help me then all of a
sudden this guy comes up
with his sunglasses and motorcycle
helmet and i knew immediately
it was keanu reeves and i of course was
like freaking out he you know
you need some help and i'm like sure so
i
i thought he was going to get into the
car i got behind the car to push
he said no i'm going to push you out of
the street you get in
so he pushed me out of the street and
then of course when people saw it was
keanu reeves helping me
everybody came down
and does he now know that that was you i
hope he doesn't honey because when i
tell you
i did all of this was showing um
and i was mortified by all i mean it was
i i
kept thinking i need to get my car
washed it was
literally months of bird poop on the
[Music]
back